dans la région de lugank au sud-est de
l'Ukraine les troupes ukrainiennes font
face à l'avancée de l'armée russe qui
tente dépercé vers l'ouest à partir de
cette enclave séparatiste l'invasion
russe entre dans son quatrième jour et
fait face à une résistance féroce des
troubles ukrainiennes loin de la
capitale assiégé les forces armées sont
pleinement mobilisées grâce notamment
aux armes envoyées par les alliés
occidentaux
selon le gouvernement ukrainien les
forces russes ont fait exploser un
important gazoduc à proximité de querquy
dans le nord-est du pays faisant
craindre une catastrophe
environnementale ce dimanche les troupes
russes sont entrés dans la ville les
combats font rage entre l'armée et les
forces ukrainienne
plus au sud dans la ville de nitro des
civils se sont rassemblés pour soutenir
la résistance ces hommes et ces femmes
assembent des cocktails Molotov à partir
des sens et de polystyrène
[Musique]
reste largement inférieur en nombre et
en armes à leurs envahisseurs russes
leurs détermination et sans faille
[Applaudissements]